mama Watson's got a viral video he's
released with Oakley and it's the golf
cart jetpack now I got to see some of
this video here and it goes about 50
miles an hour
you can stay up for 30 minutes you can
fly over trees and water hazards so what
do we what are we going to do with this
can you play golf with this um you know
it was about how do we change the game
it was about technology and innovation
and and the first responders are they're
going to be the ones that really benefit
from this the most um but you know it's
it's coming together with a company
Oakley and coming down with a company in
New Zealand that wanted to do this and
how do we partner with this and how do
we change the game of golf and when you
look at growing the game of golf you
know some people say Golf is boring I
would be a surfer just in case y'all
want to know um and so you know it's it
gets boring sometimes you know you're
out there for five hours it seems like
we're slowing down we're trying to speed
up but um
so why not bring some innovation and
something something new and let people
see this video in this innovation at me
and Oakley created and then draw them to
the game they might not be taking the
the hovercraft or the the jetpack but
they're gonna see the game go Wow some
people are actually having fun with the
game now did you actually go up in this
thing no it's um it's experimental right
now there's only a few pilots yes I said
pilots for this
and by the way there's only a few right
now being made
FAA hasn't had their their testing yeah
but you you're gonna be the first guy on
your block to have one when you but oh
yeah my name is definitely on the hat
are you a risk-taker
well no I'm really that's why that's why
I wanted to partner with Oakley they
make me seem bolder than I am and they
do they get me out of my comfort zone
and we come up with crazy ideas and
driving the the hovercraft was a lot
easier I'm driving it and being a part
of that it was uh it was scary for me
but I did it I manned up did it and now
this hover this uh hovercraft is old now
and now we're doing the jetpack and so
uh you know once it's finally safe
enough for me to get on it I wouldn't
mind trying it yeah but don't you have
the Dukes of Hazzard car
well yeah I have the general leave for
sure yeah I mean again I don't drive it
out much but um being the way you play
golf I mean if it feels like you're a
little bit more reckless than you're
letting on
or maybe yeah I'm trying to make myself
look tough yeah okay okay I'm trying to
look real time you're doing a good job
yeah thank you uh how did the British
Open treat you um it was mean to me but
um you know it was one of those things
where as we see when you look at the
time sheet you know you got a guy teeing
off at 6:30 and a guy teeing off at 416
so that day I mean there's so much
weather changed especially a place like
that right off the water it just seems
like you know if you got the good half
of the draw you were going to do pretty
well and obviously the numbers that
those two guys were shooting Phil
Mickelson and henrik stenson they they
went beyond expectations I mean that the
numbers that they were shooting were
unreal explain that to us non
professional golfers what exactly
Stenson and Mickelson just did
absolutely amazing I mean there was a
great there was a great tournament for
third place going on the numbers they
shot what Phil did and then for somebody
to actually beat him it was it was wild
it was those were two guys playing like
we've seen Tiger Woods do in the past
and we've seen McIlroy do and jordan
Spieth too I mean these were things were
they just they were both focused they're
both in what we call the zone just seems
like even time they made a mistake they
they went forward twice and so it was
just uh as a fan of golf it was
impressive to watch
would you rather finish second or barely
make the cut well since I've birdied the
last hole to make the cut um I'd rather
finish second listen if you're finished
in second place you're still playing
quality golf um especially what
Mickelson did I know at the end of your
career you want more wins but at the
same time you're you know golf was all
about consistency for years until we
started the FedEx Cup and the world
ranking system it was all about
consistency and so um you know if you
look at Jack Nicholas's record 18 wins
in 19 I think top 3s or second place
second places yeah so uh is anybody
going to get to 18 in your lifetime I
would say no just because of the talent
level what what Jack Nicklaus and
what the Great's of the game have done
to now they've brought it's a global
game and so what they've brought to the
table is is how to prepare how to
practice how to focus
Tiger brought nutrition in and working
out and so what they've brought is just
everybody in the world is playing now
and everybody's playing to a level
they're getting to that level a lot
quicker so I think it's up to win a few
of them will be amazing feat but to win
18 would be would be out of this world
when's the last time you felt helpless
on a golf course
felt like that Sunday when that wind
came on you know what on it was funny on
Thursday I was 5-under through seven
holes I was leading the golf tournament
in the first round and made a triple
bogey on eight the postage stamp it was
just a wedge it's a hundred yards right
it was a hundred and what was 107 year
oh my gosh yeah yeah big difficult we
were in between clubs that's right
exactly that wasn't sure and then the
wind's coming off the off the water
there and so I hit this wedge and it
didn't do what I wanted it to do and it
plugged in the bunker on the postage
stamp and so I had to play away from the
hole then it got into it worst lie from
the rough and then I ducked that one out
of there now it's back in the rough and
so I made a quick triple bogey so you
know you you have moments where you
think Golf is you want to be a surfer so
you feel like that sharks biting you um
have you ever had lightning come close
no I you know the story out there I'm
pretty sure it's Retief Goosen I think
they said with teeth Goosen for some
reason I have heard if goose in my head
that's been struck twice and Lee Trevino
got hit Lee Trevino yeah there's a few
people um you know we didn't have they
didn't have horns back then like they do
now on the golf course too for safety
but um I think Trevino said um you know
if there's lightning hold up a one iron
because even God can hit at one iron
right exactly nobody carries that
anymore so we can't you're not working
Goosen got hit twice I think yeah that's
what I think I'm pretty sure it was
Goosen um his careers doing pretty good
yeah he's played pretty well so maybe I
need to get struck by line he's a Bubba
Watson joining us here in New York City
Dan Patrick show uh the ability to be
able to hit a ball long we've seen
golfers are able to hit it long but do
you get do you ever get caught up in
that's what people want to see from you
like they expect you to hit it 350 and
and then if you don't are there people
say what's wrong like if you don't pull
out a driver
I imagine the gallery goes on yeah they
do actually yeah pretty funny um no
because you got to build your game you
know you're talking like Jim Furyk
earlier he plays the game that he can
play Zach Johnson
Dustin Johnson right now I'm Jason Day
they're hitting in miles um you know
you're playing what's your strength and
what you want to do and sometimes I hit
drivers I always say I've got like six
wings with the driver I've got the full
out I've got the baby I've got some soft
ones and so I'm just trying to get in
play and a driver helps me getting
rhythm if I'm hitting irons off the tee
all day it just doesn't get my full
swing and rhythm and so I'm trying to
hit the driver more just so I can get
into my golf rhythm you wear your
emotions on your sleeve and every place
else on your body but can it be
cathartic beneficial that you don't hold
it in because a lot of times golfers are
told to kind of hold it in is it helpful
to let it out and let it out in the
moment well I don't know about you guys
but but when you hold in anger not in
golf in life you know you'll blow up at
some point and so I always tell my caddy
Teddy I always tell poor Teddy I tell
him give me ten seconds I say you give
me ten seconds I'm good and you know he
talks to me so I don't worry about it
I'm like just give me ten seconds I'm
good and so that's my that's just my
release you got a release or you're
gonna just blow up at some point and so
on you know I have my moments for about
10-15 seconds and I've gotten better
over the years if you don't notice them
as much but um does your wife say
anything oh yeah my whole team's told me
uh you know when I started because I you
know you think you're the superhero you
think you should be winning you you're
looking at all these records and that's
all your life has been about his golf
and and now as a parent as a husband you
know and you know I've changed it a
little bit I've gotten softer and so you
know in oh six when I was a rookie on
tour it was very difficult
me and Teddy been together for 11 years
so he's seen the ups and downs and my
wife has too and so as a team as a
collective team like my gallery you say
here you know we we've worked on it and
gotten better at it over the over the
years who knows you better Teddy or your
wife when it comes to golf uh Ted
emotions Teddy in 11 years and again
like I said
slow on the golf course our practice so
we're looking at seven hours we're
together a day on the course and so you
know that's seven hours of emotional
drama and so he sees the highs and lows
on a course and then my wife um you know
you got to put a smile on your face to
make sure your wife is happy and making
sure she's taken care of and so does
that sign my scorecard I'm done I forget
about it um short-term memory loss I
don't think about any of them anymore
who's the best athlete in the family
gosh
well she's not here so it's me but um
you know she was you know the hard part
for her is you know me going to the
Olympics is that she made the Olympic
team she was on the Canadian team for
basketball and then got hurt so she did
get to play and so you know her being a
professional athlete being six three
she's had so many injuries so obviously
I'm scared to death of needles so she
you know she's been under the knife a
few times so I'd say she's a lot tougher
a lot more uh she prepares a lot better
and her events and so uh I would have to
say her for sure the golf cart jet pack
and fly a thousand feet in the air go 50
miles per hour stay aloft for thirty
minutes actually fly over trees and
water hazards before the commercial
break well we talked about the Olympics
a little bit in your decision to go how
long was the conversation with you and
your wife on that as soon as they said I
was on the team it was the go um you
know again because my wife not being
able to play in the Olympics we've
adopted both of our kids um so there
wasn't a scare from Zika and then I've
never had a security issue so I've never
been worried about security down there
so I was a go from the get-go my wife on
she would never hold me back from that
if that's what I wanted to do how
important is a gold medal to um you know
the gold medal is is not really what I'm
looking at um just getting on the team
and being a part of this you know the
reason why we brought golf to the
Olympics and try to bring golf to the
Olympics is get the world involved and
to grow the game the the the gold medal
or any metal is a bonus it's a bonus for
me I'm looking at it from a different
perspective I have tickets from Monday
to Tuesday mean sorry to Monday to
Saturday so that I can be a fan and I'm
going to sit with the public general
public I'm not going to
with the athletes I have my my team
going with me as you call it my gallery
got a gallery I got a gallery and so
I'll have my manager on one side in my
caddy which will be my a good friend of
mine I call him a money man but Randall
Wells he's going to be looping for me
and so we're gonna be watching the
sports I would be a fan of the Olympics
and I can't wait I've watched the
Olympics on TV but I want to go see
sports and enjoy it
Rory's comments about not growing the
game how did you react to them you know
what I played with him on Thursday and
Friday at the at the open there and it's
just one of those things where it
getting you know he's a professional
golfer an elite professional golfer and
he just didn't communicate his uh his
words the right way we talked about it
try to talk about it off camera and he
he didn't mean any harm he knows that
he's helping grow the game he does a lot
for the kids it's a great man and I just
didn't come out the way he wanted to
come out but he was not trying to be
mean he understands what his role is in
golf and he appreciates that role and he
loves it it was just the timing of this
with the zika and everything that just
wasn't right for him to go it felt like
it stayed with him through the
tournament it just felt like he was not
he was never right and Spieth either now
I know that that tournament or that
course can do it - it felt like they had
more of their minds than just trying to
win the open yeah but if you look at I
played like I said I played with Rory
and it seemed like soon as we put it out
on 18 they were number one tees right
there seems like the wind just died down
the Sun came out and so I played with
Roy the first two days and obviously he
played great he finished had a real high
finish and so you know it's just one of
those things the golf course major
championship because you're trying to
win a major you know you're so focused
you want that trophy and you know he has
he's won a few and he wants to win more
and he's trying to get to that 18 which
I said nobody'll get to but he's trying
to prove me wrong but um so you know
it's it's not really he was not thinking
about his comments or anything it was
just about it was just about he wants to
win I mean we all want to win I mean
when I get there at the Olympics that
gold medal is gonna mean the most you
imagine if you get on the medal stand
you're gonna be an emotional wreck oh
for sure I mean if I hopefully you might
be the one guy who cries more than I do
well I yeah I'm pretty good crier I'm
good at that what's that what's the
silliest thing that you ever cried about
you know what I it's it's I cry I mean I
go to church on Sundays when I'm home
when I'm not I miss a cut and so that
makes you cry I cry then and but I cry
every every time but you know what I cry
on sad stories I just get why am I so
lucky I'm so blessed you know why am i
able to do these great things and
wonderful fun things and then there's
tragedy and so even if it's in my local
community its tragedy and so it just uh
it really gets to me and then when you
see sad stories like I just can't give
enough to help these people did you cry
a tin cup you didn't at the end of tin
cup you didn't cry did you know cuz I
was mad I was more mad at Tim Cook cause
he got a Waffle House logo on him and I
can't I can't get one path without your
ideal that would be if I can get if I
can get a sponsorship from Waffle House
we'll be good what didn't John Daly have
Dunkin Donuts
and Jenny Craig on the same shirt like
so
and then probably a Hooters in there too
for John some of that is true
yes some of that is true that's pretty
good did you ever play with Daly
oh yeah you know what he's a past
champion at the the open the British
Open and um so I sat with him at lunch
one day and we were just talking and him
and his him and his grown his his I
think he sponsored by loudmouth so the
loudmouth guy was there so it was uh no
we had a great conversation he's a great
guy he'll give the shirt off his back
you know we all make mistakes don't want
the shirt off his back though no no no
no I wasn't dancing with the pants and
pants are great no way we'd see them
right would you wear those nobody sees a
picture where I know it's close to
loudmouth you could you could wear these
oh for sure I'd pull that off yeah yeah
now do you have the green jackets
good Bobby just say you wanted to pull
these off no I said I could pull those
all you could pull those and you'd let
me
oh wow wait a minute what just happened
here so the green jackets are back at
Augusta yes they you have to think you
get them for a year and then you you put
them back so every time I show up on
property somehow it magically appears in
my locker
via I have a locker there yes the oddest
place you took your green jacket ID you
know what respect for what the Masters
is oh come on you had to be doing no I'm
being serious
the
craziest thing I did is because we
adopted our son two weeks before I
wrapped him up in it like a blanket no
um that was it it wasn't I've never done
anything crazy with it just because the
first time I want it I put it in my
closet nobody got to see it no way got
to touch it take a picture with it
because I just out of respect for the
Masters in and hopefully one day they
they want me to be a member there so
that you know there's other reasons
right what if your son had an accident
in the green jacket that's fine yeah you
know it was funny I have a story on that
to chuck about my stories but on the oh
and the ceremonies there getting the
green jacket on the putting green he
actually had an accident back there with
the members in the media and one of the
members said don't worry about it you
know talking to my wife because I was
getting jacket said don't worry about it
but that is the first baby ever to be
changed on the on the jacket ceremony it
was pretty good the the birth
certificate doesn't say Bubba nope no I
know that you probably explained this
quite a few times of how we came up with
Bubba and have you ever changed the
story here is it always so J just
depends on where we're at but no it's
it's Gary Lester Watson jr. is my legal
name and then somehow I came to Bubba
but um when I was born
real chubby in the face and my dad was
the biggest Yankees fan Don Mattingly
was my favorite growing up wanted me to
play baseball wanna be a to be a pitcher
for the Yankees and then I found he
found out I was left-handed but um so
when I was first born Bubba Smith I know
him as police academy you know the guy
from police academy were Baltimore coli
tower right being so um so that's how I
know him and and so my dad said oh man I
got a Bubba I got a football player not
a baseball player and you know my mom to
this day since my dad's no longer with
us she now she claims that she's the one
that came up with it so your mom's role
in your life though I think she might
have been the first person you hugged
after you won the green jacket yeah and
12 yeah she was that she was there and
that you know it was amazing just you
know a couple of golfers uh gosh who
were they Ben Crane Rickie Fowler they
were waiting they were that they had oh
they had to leave the clubhouse and go
down to ten green to watch me and so it
was it was wild to see that
but yeah my mom being there my mom's
hard work she had a paper route she had
a regular job and a paper route slip a
couple hours a night for four gosh pray
about six seven years of my life when I
was in high school and before and just
to just to be able to take me places and
buy me things my dad worked hard and so
for her to be there my dad not being
there and I became a new dad the week
before I mean when you add up the whole
story obviously it made me cry like a
baby but it was uh you know from a mom
and everything her hard work and
dedication to get me where I am
well you held on for dear life it's like
you didn't want to let go mom that day
yeah for sure it was it was tough I mean
you know mom sees her son succeeding she
sees her hard work paying off and my
hard work paying off and my dad not
being there and me and doun dad it was
it was and then she sees these golfers
why are these golfers here watching her
son so it made her made her appreciate
me a little bit more thing well congrats
and good luck with Oakley and I saw that
you brought in something here for the
man cave now I would like to explain
what this year well the key is there's a
big head over here so I figured that my
big head over the right so I wanted the
creepy head to have I mean oh God
am I really that ugly I mean you don't
have to laugh don't know that ours that
one better which one no no no I this one
looks a little bit ugly I don't put that
next to you but I don't even think I
don't really don't wanna touch it
actually but it's kind of creepy so we
were shooting that you look sweaty too
well this is tough day you know um got
the mullet gone right so uh we were
shooting the video or we're gonna shoot
the video and they had to put this uh
gosh I don't know what you call it what
do you you put all this look like a
mummy I guess you'd say and had to pull
our stuff and put two holes so I could
breathe out of my nose for 30 minutes in
about the 28th minute I was like take it
off take it off I can't do this anymore
and so they made this mold because they
were gonna have a stunt double for the
video shoot because I couldn't I
couldn't fly it because of FF you know
the the regulation said and the pilots
and they said you're gonna hurt yourself
and so so then we decided not to use the
stunt double because we don't want to
fake that I was flying it when I really
wasn't so uh so now just got a creepy
face for myself
are you leaving that creepy face with us
yeah if you want it
Paulie are we allowed to have this we
should check with the Oakley Pete yeah I
don't know we put the glasses funny I
just looked back at the Oakley people I
think no I was gonna I was just gonna
put it in my house you know my trophy
case and saw it well we were gonna put
it on display be a loner like like the
green jacket one year yeah keep it for a
year all right and then I'll come down
to Augusta
I'll just bring that head with me yeah
I'll follow you around take it to Rio
and we'll just oh there you go yeah I'll
go to Rio with them you can check out
the videos with Oakley the golf jet Kart
jet pack the golf cart jet pack and fly
a thousand feet in the air now where
where can they go see the videos is
there an actual address here web address
or yeah I've Oakley's put it out I've
put it out of my own social media okay
and then we've been putting it out
everywhere yeah we'll put it on on our
website it's pretty fascinating there go
50 miles per hour stay up for 30 minutes
and fly over trees water hazards good
luck at the travelers defending your
title and I hope seeing Rio perfect I
can't wait the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience